[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
de la actualidad africana Mi nombre es
comenzamos con los titulares
6 países africanos se ofrecen a llevar
la paz a Ucrania y actuar como
intermediarios entre los presidentes
Vladimir Putin y mimir selensky esta
iniciativa parte de una fundación
llamada la fundación bajada su director
es nuestro invitado
la situación de seguridad en Nigeria no
mejora además de las violencias yadista
y de las bandas criminales los
conflictos entre pastores y agricultores
por la tierra y los recursos de agua se
cobran decenas de víctimas en el centro
y el norte del país y por último nos
vamos a marrakes en Marruecos donde tuvo
lugar el Festival Internacional de
robótica los participantes jóvenes de
más de 50 países de África y de América
Latina compitieron por la mejor
invención con la transición energética
como tema principal
pero empezamos con esta iniciativa
africana por la paz en Ucrania la
fundación
dirigida por el empresario francés
olivi está detrás de este proyecto de
mediación entre
Moscú y kiev y liderado por seis jefes
de estado africanos la propuesta fue
revelada al público por el presidente
sudafricano City
un grupo de jefes de estado africanos
Consideró que África debía presentar una
iniciativa una iniciativa de paz que
pudiera ayudar a contribuir a la
solución de este conflicto y facilitado
por la fundación Brasil pudimos tener
estas discusiones
presente la iniciativa en nombre de los
siguientes países también senegal con
obras hábil uganda Egipto y Sudáfrica
también
los dos líderes con los que tuve la
oportunidad de hablar a saber el
presidente Putin y el presidente
acordaron que estarían dispuestos a
recibir a una misión de jefes de estado
africanos en Moscú y Jeff
mosco and Give para entender mejor esta
propuesta estamos con el director de la
fundación
que está detrás del proyecto
puede contarnos más acerca de la
fundación bajada
si la funda sombra sebil trabaja sobre
tres temas Paz salud y preservación de
medio ambiente he tenido de paz Es sobre
todo resolución de conflictos
en términos de salud pública trabajamos
sobre el tema de la lucha en contra de
las fases medicinas
y en término de medio ambiente es la
perseveración de la Cuenca del Congo Y
por qué ha lanzado la fundación esta
iniciativa
el objetivo de esta iniciativa es lograr
un diálogo entre Rusia y Ucrania que
ayude a encontrar una solución pacífica
al conflicto actual que afecta a
millones de Vidas tantos en los países
enfrentados como en todo el mundo y
establecer también una plataforma de
diálogo destinada a conseguir acuerdos
que permitan liberar los envíos de
cereales y fertilizantes críticos para
su envío a África miticando así el
riesgo potencial de hambruna con el
continente y como lo dice
nuestro presidente fundador
aún reconociendo la complejidad es que
han entraña creemos que este primer paso
crucial puede allanar el camino hacia
una paz duradera
la probabilidad de éxito de esta
propuesta
sabemos que la fundación Y estos seis
países africanos no van a resolver el
problema en los días que vienen pero el
el la creencia que tenemos es que
podemos podemos ayudar
entrenar una forma de diálogo que sea
diferente y lo interesante es saber que
el presidente Putin como el presidente
cedensquí han aceptado discutir con los
seis jefes de estado africanos Y esto es
realmente nuevo
desde el empiezo de la guerra
Por qué haber escogido estos seis países
especificamente
Es una derivación muy equilibrada con
países conocidos por ser por rusos como
Sudáfrica país es neutrales como Egipto
y la República del Congo un país que ha
mostrado simpatía con ucraina como
zambia y un país que mantiene las
mejores relaciones con los países
occidentales senegal cuyo jefe de estado
era el presidente de la unión africana
en el momento en que se concibió esta
misión en diciembre 2022
Lisa gabaldi Muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en África siete días
cambiamos de tema al menos 85 muertos es
el elevado balance establecido por las
autoridades nigerianas tras nuevos
enfrentamientos en aldeas del distrito
de mangú en el estado de plató en el
centro del país las regiones
noroccidentales y centrales del de
Nigeria son regularmente escenario de
conflictos y tensiones por el uso de la
tierra y los recursos
hídricos entre comunidades agrícolas y
ganaderas
en el centro de Nigeria las tensiones
entre pastores y agricultores son cada
vez mayores desde el 15 de mayo un ciclo
mortal de represalias está en marcha el
asesinato de un agricultor seguido de
otro asesinato de un pastor a manos de
los familiares de la agricultor inició
un círculo de represalias que acabó
provocando la muerte de al menos 85
personas estos Aldeanos reunidos
alrededor de una fosa común entierran a
las víctimas
ayer hubo un grave atentado los pastores
nos tendieron una emboscada tuvimos que
arrastrarnos por el suelo bajo las balas
y Dios nos salvó a todos
incendiaron todas las casas quemaron
todos los cereales destruyeron las
propiedades hubo saqueos los vimos
incluso Vimos a Los mercenarios los
atacantes
para los supervivientes irse es la única
de seguir con vida miles de personas se
pusieron en camino en busca de un lugar
seguro donde refugiarse la violencia
recurrente en esta parte de Nigeria
enfrenta a agricultores sedentarios y a
pastores nómadas por el uso de la tierra
y los recursos hídricos los agricultores
acusan a los pastores de destruir sus
tierras con su ganado y los pastores
afirman que ya no tienen acceso a las
tierras de pastoreo el conflicto ha
provocado una grave crisis humanitaria y
de seguridad con ataques de grupos
armados e interminables represalias
entre comunidades para el recién elegido
presidente volatinumú que tomará
posesión de su cargo a finales de mayo
se trata de un enorme desafío el
ejército nigeriano ya está luchando
contra una insurgencia vista desde hace
14 años en el noreste contra grupos
separatistas en el sureste contra la
piratería en el Golfo de Guinea y contra
los secuestros perpetrados por
delincuentes armados en todo el país y
las propias fuerzas de seguridad son
acusadas regularmente de graves
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
como Lo acabamos de ver los problemas de
seguridad de Nigeria son numerosos pero
volvamos al conflicto entre pastores
nómadas y agricultores sedentarios en
este mapa podemos ver que el conflicto
que la disputa se concentra en las
regiones Norte y centro del país
históricamente estas zonas eran las
llanuras fértiles de Nigeria donde
pastores y agricultores coexistían sin
problemas sin embargo la sequía de vida
principalmente al cambio climático el
crecimiento demográfico y la
adjudicación de grandes parcelas a
terratenientes han expulsado a los
pastores de sus zonas tradicionales de
pastoreo lo que ha llevado a la
situación que se vive hoy
además como los pastores proceden
tradicionalmente de la etnia fulani las
tensiones Se volvieron comunitarias y
las milicias étnicas que se han formado
están en conflicto armado
pasamos ahora a un tema completamente
distinto dejamos Nigeria y viajamos al
norte de África a Marruecos donde tuvo
lugar la primera competición
internacional joven de robótica del
norte de África La competición se
celebró en la ciudad de marrakech y en
ella participaron jóvenes de todo el
mundo que trabajaron en propuestas
innovadoras para avanzar en el
compromiso de la transición energética
tema central del torneo nuestra
corresponsalía catalana estuvo allí
los mejores equipos jóvenes de robótica
del mundo niños y adolescentes de entre
9 y 16 años de más de 50 países traen
consigo propuestas innovadoras
relacionadas con la producción y los
usos de la energía marrakes acoge la
competición internacional de robótica un
evento que llega por primera vez a
Marruecos y al norte de África gracias
al trabajo de la asociación look por la
ciencia y la tecnología que se dedican a
promover la robótica educativa
especialmente entre los jóvenes sin
medios económicos
lo más importante de esta competición es
que los niños aprenden muchas cosas
aprenden competencias transversales el
coding la comunicación y al mismo tiempo
descubren la otra cultura los
participantes son valorados en cuatro
aspectos diseños de robots juego de
robots la comunicación y los valores
fundamentales de la competición
nuestro proyecto trata sobre utilizar
energía de yogas en la ingeniería del y
el impacto que nuestro proyecto tendrá
en la sociedad es que reducirá las
emisiones de dióxido de carbono en la
atmósfera
su equipo ha diseñado un robot para dar
solución a un problema real vinculado
con la energía en esta carpa todos los
grupos exponen comparten y celebran sus
trabajos un Jurado profesional los
puntúa y gana el certamen el equipo que
más puntos haya logrado sumar de todas
las competiciones del torneo
el proyecto de nosotros creamos es un
interruptor inteligente que funciona
para apagar las luces automáticamente
Cuando nadie las está usando funciona
con una arduino el sensor va a empezar a
captar y en 15 minutos quiero capte
ningún movimiento va a pagar la luz
automáticamente el proyecto consiste en
una balsada de riego que está en el que
hay paneles solares para así generar
energía de manera limpia y ocupando un
espacio sin uso
nuestro proyecto es un condensador de
sonido que transforma las ondas sonoras
en energía eléctrica por ejemplo vamos a
instalar nuestro proyecto en una rotonda
donde hay bullicio y ese ruido lo
transformaremos en energía eléctrica
aprendemos muchas cosas como el trabajo
en equipo y los valores fundamentales
un evento transversal que busca seguir
reuniendo en África a jóvenes de todas
las clases sociales y partes del mundo y
que más allá de la competición promueve
el conocimiento y los valores
fundamentales para construir sociedades
más justas y sostenibles
así llegamos al final de esta edición de
África 7 días los dejamos con las
imágenes del festival Gracias por
acompañarnos la actualidad internacional
continúa en France 24 y Francia 24.com
[Música]